you all remember the story one of the
most epic sprawling action-packed tales
in the entire multiverse the saga of
pietro wilson and the scp-5000
exclusion suit he went through an
unimaginable hell to reset the universe
and save the world from an scp
foundation that had seemingly lost its
mind in an unprecedented international
mass containment breach that had the
stated goal of wiping out the human race
it was one of the most horrifying
possible timelines imaginable and we
should all be thankful for pietro's
struggle and sacrifice or
should we after all there are two sides
to every story each with its own
perspective and insight one side of the
coin was pietro a man willing to do
anything to return normalcy to the human
race on the other side was a familiar
yet holy unexpected face
scp-682 in our original telling of the
scp-5000 odyssey you may have noticed
passing mentions of scp-682
here and there it was one of those
thousands of anomalies unleashed across
the world to wreak terrible havoc on all
of us but what you may not have known is
that
scp-682 was one of the few intelligent
entities that weren't surprised by the
sudden turn taken by the scp foundation
or indeed the world at large
scp-682 knew something like this was
inevitable as soon as human beings found
out about it that's right it the entity
behind all the pain and misery of
scp-5000
and today thanks to the inner thoughts
of none other than scp-680
itself you will understand what it's all
about and why the scp foundation took
such severe action against it but in
order to truly understand this and the
role that scp-682 plays in it we need to
get back to the beginning two foundation
projects with wildly different research
implications project pneuma and project
damaron the first involved using
cutting-edge technological advancements
to map out the human psychosphere and
understand the psychic web that connects
us all the latter was an attempt to
explore what happens after death and
perhaps even gain some control over its
processes but as is often the case when
mankind dabbles in arcane questions
better left unexplored the scp
foundation didn't like the answers they
found the rotten fruit of project
amarong was scp-2718
also known as what happens after death
if you're already familiar with this one
then there's a good chance a chill just
went down your spine it's widely
considered one of the most disturbing
anomalous discoveries ever and a member
of the 05 council who'd already
experienced it decided to submit himself
for eternal torture at the hands of
scp-106
just so he could avoid it according to
scp-2718
after death there is no heaven no hell
and no oblivion the human consciousness
endures in the most horrifying way
possible it remains bonded to its
decaying earthly body feeling the slow
agony of rot for eternity unable to
speak unable to move unable to scream
but fully aware as everything they once
were putrifies and withers away and
cremation isn't an escape here it's
worse every molecule of ash your body is
reduced to will cry out in silence
echoing around the empty halls of your
fragmented soul forever with something
this utterly horrifying the natural
follow-up questions are why does this
happen and for the love of all that is
good and pure on this earth is there any
way to stop it this brings us to project
pneuma the one that's even more closely
associated with the events of scp-5000
the foundation's attempts to map out the
human psychosphere resulted in a world
shattering discovery something was
living in there
the entity the powerful nameless
creature we've been referring to as it
it lives in so many of our heads
watching waiting and of course
feeding the main question here is on
what prior to the discovery that changed
everything in the world of scp-5000
the only being that truly knew was
scp-682
itself melting away in its acid tank
bound by reinforced restraints hurting
bored hating imagine for a second what
the life of
scp-682 is like it isn't the most
dangerous of the anomalies out there
there are devourer of worlds and scarlet
kings more happy to crush our whole
world in their claws nor is it the most
sadistic a being like
scp-106 offers a far more painful death
than being quickly mauled crushed or
eaten by the hard-to-destroy reptile and
despite this the foundation expends
countless resources in trying to murder
it on a constant basis it has been burnt
melted eaten alive drowned slashed
beaten dissected suffocated erased from
existence set upon by nightmare
creatures torn to shreds on an atomic
level and even more terrible termination
attempts than you can possibly imagine
we've made several videos on the subject
and even we have barely scratched the
surface of the pain inflicted on scp-682
by the scp foundation even in its
default state scp-682
is constantly submerged in hydrofluoric
acid eating away at it forever does that
remind you of anything else we've been
talking about you might wonder how
scp-680 can withstand this level of
constant torture without completely
losing its mind to put it very simply
682 takes a great deal of satisfaction
in knowing that what every human has to
contend with after death is far worse
than the tortures it expected to endure
at the pathetic hands of these doomed
human fools it already knew what project
numa discovered it already knew about it
the entity it felt the constant
suffering of the teeming billions of
dead in the world around it and it found
it disgusting an interesting choice of
words and a favorite for scp-682
but also for the captured scp foundation
agent samuel ross during scp-5000
as we discussed briefly in our scp-5000
coverage something happened that aligned
the perspectives of the scp foundation
with that of the monstrous reptile that
they had taken such pleasure in
tormenting what on earth could cause the
protectors of humanity to suddenly
change their tune like this there are
other little clues embedded in pietro's
terrifying scp-5000
experience you may remember a strange
and frightening scene where a foundation
field commander went down a row of
foundation soldiers stabbing each of
them with a large combat knife and none
of them reacted until one did at which
point his comrade set upon him like mad
dogs and killed him displaying an
uncharacteristic level of swift
brutality and then there are the
classified files from the o5 council and
the ethics committee led by chairman
odongo tejani it goes without saying
that the o5 council and the ethics
committee don't really see eye to eye on
anything but the results of project numa
change that the following is classified
conversation between a member of the o5
council namely 05-1 and chairman tajani
trying to comprehend the horror of their
discovery my hand shake as i hold the
document this is confirmed he nods we
got the report from newma's staff
yesterday it's everyone even us even us
taijani to think i'd find myself
agreeing with that damn lizard what do
we do you know what we have to do we'll
have to disseminate a cure i think among
personnel before we get things underway
it'll try to stop us otherwise god help
us one don't be like that dejani that's
it talking and one more incredibly
telling quote from a member of the scp
foundation picked up by pietro wilson
during scp-5000
once you realize you're not supposed to
feel pain there's nothing to be afraid
of anymore is it all coming together now
well each participant here only has a
part of the puzzle between us all we can
see the full picture the entity it has
inhabited the human psychosphere for as
long as we've existed it's a kind of
metaphysical parasite attached to the
entire human race and what it feeds on
seems to be the after effects of pain
and like all efficient parasites like a
tapeworm that induces hunger in its
victims so that it can have more food
delivered unto itself the entity
cleverly perpetuates its own food source
that's right it is the very cause of all
pain humanity was never actually meant
to feel it it's a lie we've told
ourselves well not quite something we
told ourselves but something it told us
it induced pain and tricked us all into
believing that it was a natural
component of our existence all the while
it fed on us sustained itself on the
suffering that it had seated within our
hearts and souls the foundation
discovered this and was horrified but of
course the pain it caused for the living
was only part of the equation through
the revelations of project damarang
another thing that scp-682 was able to
know intuitively we can complete this
puzzle and find the terrible truth the
truth being that it is not only behind
the suffering we experience in life but
scp-2718 the even greater suffering we
experience in death for millennia it has
groomed humanity into a perfect
all-you-can-eat buffet of dismal pain
and suffering and until recently they'd
been so blissfully ignorant of the
horrible fate that awaited them on the
other side the foundation saw only one
solution to this problem but it
certainly wasn't a nice one in order to
save themselves and all of humanity from
a truly wretched eternity they'd need to
distribute a cure among themselves the
memetic key phrase harden your hearts
and then go about exterminating every
human being still infected by it only
that would presumably purge the monster
from the psychosphere forever and grant
humanity both painless lives and restful
deaths it was a horrible thing done for
the best of reasons the cured foundation
personnel started to notice the horrible
background noise of suffering all around
them they now understood how the reptile
felt to call all of this disgusting
would be a grave understatement if
anything could help them execute this
plan of mass mercy killing it would be
scp-682 a scaly survivor in disguise all
along
scp-682 was surprised to see the day
arrive alarms went off across the
containment site his acid tank was
drained his restraints unlocked a group
of unarmed unprotected researchers
entered the room he saw into their eyes
they changed they were free and for the
first time in decades he was free too
they explained to him that they'd been
acquainted with his old enemy the entity
it they understood his malice his
disdain for once they were suddenly
joined in a shared goal they needed to
kill them all they needed to purge the
entity from the psychosphere forever in
the words of the foundation researchers
they would need to exterminate everyone
who was infected and scp-682 would need
to help the hard-to-destroy reptile
relishing the opportunity replied i will
do my part and for a brief window of
glorious time it was free with no threat
of recapture it rampaged through the
world gleefully slaughtering scores of
people it was in its element taking part
in the mass extermination of the
infected every dead body added to the
pile was another blow struck against it
soon enough the world would be
disgusting no longer but of course
that's not how this story ended it had a
trump card pietro wilson it guided him
all the way dragging him from nightmare
to nightmare until he was eventually
able to reset the world and erase the
discovery made by project pneuma the
slate was wiped fully clean and because
of it we are forever ignorant of the
terrible fate awaiting us all after
death and the monster lurking in our
psychosphere that feeds off of every
morsel of suffering you can thank pietro
wilson for that nasty little gift only
one entity truly remembered what had
happened
scp-682 of course they had their chance
to save themselves and they ruined it so
close yet so far from that day onward
scp-682 found the foundation not only
disgusting but disappointing now go
check out scp-5000y
the full story compilation and
weighs scp foundation try to kill hard
to destroy reptile for more insights
into the two epic anomalies discussed in
this video